à Saint-Étienne on prépare l'avenir
comme en témoigne ses images les jeunes
de l'école de football sur les pelouses
des terrains de l'étyvalier
ils sont plus d'une centaine tous les
jeudis qui bénéficient des conseils des
joueurs professionnels de la SNCF
au moment où une crise grave menace une
football ces images trouvent au moins
que ce sport est toujours aussi
populaire dans la jeunesse et que l'AS
Saint-Étienne poursuit sa politique des
jeunes une politique qui lui a permis de
se hisser à la toute première place du
football français de cette pépinière
sortira peut-être de nouveaux vérita
paulny ou autres littoral